so that whole Nicholas Cage thing Kevin
Smith had this q a session right and
someone brought up hey weren't you on
that Nicholas Cage Superman Project so
they call him the asking about Superman
and writing the show and it was called
Superman lives so he's sitting there
with the producer John Peters and he
says stuff like oh I don't want him
wearing a cape because he looks like it
then one of his other demands was he has
to fight a giant spider at the end but
that producer John Peters went on to
produce a movie called wild wild west or
at the end there's a giant
spider that's why in this movie we see
Nicholas Cage and he's fighting a giant
spider it's in reference to that